talk about mr. Elon Musk let's talk
about it what does it mean to take the
red pill Elon Musk certainly wants you
to he tweeted take the red pill and then
strangely flower and the flower is what
the Socialists put in their Twitter name
so there's no red pill emoji is there I
don't think they're anything no no yeah
yeah it's got to be red so I think he
might have been just going for the red
motif the Red Rose or choice well this
is what we get it's the weirdest thing
ever
Ivanka Trump quote tweets Elon Musk
taken Wow and then Lily wachowski one of
the creators of the matrix yeah F both
of you you know what man what is
happening this is this right here
summarizes is it or exemplifies the
problem I have with the cultural left
mhm and I'm sure you know there probably
some conservatives who do this the
similar behavior but cussing at someone
isn't a point about anything no you're
right it's it's a virtue signal it's a
tendency of the cultural left it's a
virtue signal it's screaming no when
they announce right as president that's
what it is that's all I see is that
video now yeah that's it all these
people doing this just like yeah that's
like oh you're just screaming what what
did he vodka Trump ever do to anybody
she was the daughter of Trump
I believe that's her main right now I
get it yeah right see it makes sense
into the father you know you look at
from a different perspective
it's like oh yeah she's actually really
nice like Trump I guess you know Trump
like he's a he's a nasty dude you know I
mean like yeah I didn't he actually say
I'm a mean guy but I work for you yeah
like I watch consumer owns up to it at
least right he's a he's a cutthroat yeah
isn't that the whole thing about being a
good businessman you got a beat
cutthroat that's how I mean it's not
that aggressive right and he's bombastic
he's arrogant okay
and he's like I mean guy but I work for
you and people love it yes Bell
coach we're always ready to bellicose
yeah now look I understand why people
like Trump I understand why people don't
like him but what did a vodka did
anybody do anything she's like just
smiling and like just doing I mean I
guess people don't like that she has a
clothing company or something or
whatever I don't know I don't care what
it's the weirdest thing if there didn't
he appoint her what what position does
she have I mean yeah I have like an
important position that's a criticism of
Trump though it's like that trumps
appointing his family members and
putting them and you know surrounding
himself but even then it's like a weak
criticism it's like dude people go I'm
not criticized I'm just I'm just asking
I mean other people if she isn't
qualified though then then she may
deserve some criticism also but would
know I think it's a criticism of the
person who put her in the position she's
not qualified for all right I guess
you're right yeah like if Ivanka is like
look if you had somebody whose IQ was 80
uh-huh and they got appointed to some
job you'd be like why did you appoint
this person in this job you wouldn't go
to the person whose IQ is 80 and be like
it's your fault yeah I feel a good point
talk to him yeah but if they're nice to
me I don't know why be mean to them
anyway let's talk about what it means to
be red pill because that's that's the
big question this look so here's the
weird life story Tim enlighten us oh
well we'll just wait just what cuz I
there's a lot of ways to talk about it
Elon Musk falls foul of his
mother-in-law uh it is he married to
grind no yeah rhymes his mom of his Bo's
mom Grimes's mom slams daughter's
partner for tweeting right-wing take the
red pill meme accusing him of blaring
men's rights activism BS but he was
praised by Ivanka okay I don't think
Elon Musk knows what the red pill means
yeah I think didn't he actually like
tweet about the matrix just right before
watching it yeah yeah you probably
watched the matrix and was like yes
everyone should like open their eyes cuz
he worries about AI I know yeah well I
mean I I mean it feels like everyone has
different views of what taking the red
pill even means yeah it's like there's
there's a big spectrum out there think
of it like a different gender there's
there's many different genders of red
pill there are can I say that
right there right now the dominant idea
of what red pilled is is basically that
you're going to vote for Trump or vote
Republican or something okay it is a bit
nebulous yeah yeah then there's like I
feel like that's kind of newer that's
like a newer term relatively it's been
around for years okay but going back
even further the red pill referred to
this community of I don't know how to
describe it but it's kind of like I
don't describe it the game the game is
like the movie or no there's a book
called the game and it's about how men
can pick up women and the ways they have
to act and the things that women want
okay and the red the red pill community
was about you know like here's what you
need to do to actually understand the
desires of women or something like that
I'm probably getting the general
philosophy wrong because the media
always does for sure they call it men's
right stuff it's not I think the closer
you can get to it is it's an online
community of people who study various
evolutionary sites like various bits of
evolutionary psychology is an effort for
dating okay and you can criticize them
you can complement them whatever you
think I don't care at the point is just
like an accurate description it's called
the red pill and then the general idea
of what the red pill always was was just
waking up yeah that's I mean I first
heard the term and what is it 1999 when
the matrix came out when I watched The
Matrix I wasn't solving the theatres
blew my mind I was like this is one of
the best movies ever it's like taking
the red pill opening your mind revealing
the truth yeah you know finding out
what's really going on and that's still
kind of what it's supposed to mean
that's what I mean that's what I always
get also so does woke getting woke yes
they mean literally the same thing yeah
I mean I think that's altered though way
faster than the red pill so I think
that's tiered way left really fast no no
the left calls what their awakening
bonus like when you finally learn about
male privilege and white privilege now
you're woke you've awoken to you know
the truth you know and it's funny
because being red pilled around to the
matrix is essentially the same thing but
the truth is different
yeah but getting woke is like realizing
that and then falling flat on your face
oh you're woke now no I think like Oh in
your face it's taking the blue pill
maybe it's mixing them and then no not
really
realizing what's happening and then
tripping and coming out in your life
that's kind of yeah exactly
yeah that could explain it out just
going too far like oh now I know
everything so I'm gonna take over the
world no no I think what it feels like
one way you did it I mean is if you took
both pills they both be counteracting
yourself so you'd be half in and half
out so your perception will be all
warped and twisted or nothing would
happen at all and they were just oh so
no I'm the same I mean one way one way
to describe woke 'no siz that they've
got you know half half cocked brainless
ideas yeah that's where like someone
just wrote one day and then published
and everyone's like I'm gonna say that's
true and it's like actually not really
good that's perfect it's basically
taking both because they're they're nit
picking and choosing what's perfect for
record their battles and then like
favoring other things where the red pill
is like I'm accepting all of the truth
no matter yeah everything's being
revealed better yet we can say it is
that when they take both the blue and
the red pill they do wake up but their
brain is still halfway attached to the
fake reality here so they're in the real
world saying things that make no sense
and you're like man weird because they
have this parallel alternate dimension
in their brain whether like or they're
still connected to the matrix maybe
they're like oh this is a weird world
close my eyes again I'm telling you I
see a giant green fairy monster you need
to understand the power and you're like
that's not real your brain is not in
reality to him so now I think for the
most part red pill broke red pill kind
of just means that it for the most part
means like you you understand the lies
of the media and the establishment but
it basically implies you're voting for
Trump or like your your your overtly you
know on board with a Trump train or
Republicans or whatever okay like a good
example is how people keep saying Tim
take the red pill and it's like I don't
understand what that's supposed to mean
in the context of me constantly telling
you the media is lying to you right like
every single way that I've known you
would have taken the you've been had
I eat the red pill for breakfast I'm
concerned what what a lot of a lot of
Trump supporters say is that I'm a
dealer I don't make my own supply work
that's funny I worked for these
companies man ice I've watched them lie
I've watched them fail and so I was I
was watching the media lie and so I left
and I'm like hey guess what the media's
lying and then it turns out that much of
the media's lies lines up with Democrats
narratives mm-hmm it's the aesthetic but
it's the establishment that's what it is
yeah right so the establishment
Republicans a lot of them retired some
of them are still there but for the most
part you know Trump booted amount
brought in some a bunch of new people
and so the establishment right now is
just the remnants of the Democrats and
their media cohorts and it's obvious
Jacobin magazine which is the socialist
magazine and wrote an article saying
Democrats were spreading Russian
propaganda that's the truth and I'm like
it's so weird to see the Socialists in
the Trump supporters in agreement on
what's really happening yeah like that's
being that's that's waking up that's the
red pill you can have horrible political
ideas but you understand the under look
you can understand the underlying like
truth of reality the objective reality
that the media lied the whole time that
Russia gate was fake it's all nonsense
so that's why I think for the most part
it's a reference to like colloquially
for these people you are on board for
Trump you're wearing a mug a hat you're
like totally on board not necessarily it
could just be that community okay but I
think for the most part you can just say
this like red pill is the cultural right
and woke miss as the cultural left so it
seems that way for Elon Musk he
basically just told the world join the
culture war on the right that's what he
basically said whether he realizes it or
not well I mean he's been bragging on
all the Democrats for a while now well
they've been given a hard time yeah yeah
absolutely County right that's why
that's why you know I can say it I don't
know if if he knows what he's actually
saying maybe he does because he's he's
wants to leave California he's yeah he's
getting attacked by Democrats that
Lorena Gonzales woman who said eff you
and he said message you know received
yeah so maybe he was like
take the red pill fine half these people
it's like how he I don't see why he
wouldn't leave California like didn't he
say take the doesn't make sense
oh no it's right here yeah he's like
when you take dayquil and I call at the
same time did you seriously just take
both pills with a puffle oh I just swore
great now we're in trouble
wTF is wrong with you well there you
have it everyone now was a wait sorry I
start swimming everybody oops oops I I
did say earlier that we followed up with
an oops fix it in post
so so the next the next thing that
happens is you know we have a Lulu Chow
ski we have stories getting written
about it the director was infuriated by
social media banter in which musk and
Trump tweeted about the red pill why it
is banter why I don't get it
yeah who cares yeah if why you care at
all if Lily Wu Chao ski like shared a
skate video of mine I wouldn't care yeah
laughs you don't share my skate videos
from a long time ago
ruff why would I care this is a case of
virtue signaling afraid yes it's serious
they she Laura bow for bow wants a
little piece of the action that's that's
what I've seen here that's all I'm
relevant again yep yeah they're
referencing them a try what happens to
that yeah those are two famous people
that are out there mom let me get a
piece yeah I'm sorry but it gets better
oh great new statesman why we should be
worried that Ivanka Trump has taken the
red pill oh come on the US president's
daughter has confirmed that she in
common with others on the political
fringes denies widely accepted truths
about society what dude
Donald oh I can't wait to hear what they
have to say about this wait Donald Trump
tweeted a video several times now of a
reporter in Long Island who was getting
yelled at by her by just for saying your
fake news uh-huh and CNN brian Stelter
writes this article about what happened
and the opening line is something like
I've written a lot about far-right
radicalization but this video like
exemplifies it better than anything I'm
like wait you mean a bunch of suburban
long
Island middle aged individuals
complaining about Mia lying is far right
you know if they're coming out in
uniforms preaching my traditionalism in
a free market I might consider that far
right right but these are just regular
people holding signs saying your fake
news or whatever yeah and and CNN's like
they're far so these people are so far
left the meme is that they're they're
all the way in the far left so
everything to the right of the alt you
know that point a limp them basically is
far right yeah that's exactly it when
you're so far left moderate is fringe
she didn't here's the best part right
cerumen Evis this woman who wrote this
this is this is such a great example of
fake news what what is this what truths
has she not accepted simply by saying
the word taken yeah she may have just
been like who it's a meme it's funny
we're in the matrix and you might have
no idea what it means
yeah they write based off one word taken
that it means everything oh it's all
trite oh my oh my good you bunk admits
it it's already too much here's what she
writes on Sunday afternoon just days
after the birth of his seventh child
the billionaire technology entrepreneur
Elon Musk tweeted to his audience of 34
million followers to take the red pill
the term is popular in Internet
community such as such as the alt-right
and the Manos sphere that's that it's
like my earlier thought okay the people
that write the traditional men kind of
kind of Manos fear is a different thing
okay but what if I said take the red
pill the term is popular in Internet
communities that are big fans of the
matrix I could frame it that way too
yeah exactly clearly manipulating people
because well what is right red pills are
reference to the matrix neo is offered
the choice between the blue pill and the
red pill blah blah blah the phrase has
come to mean rejecting widely accepted
truths no it doesn't particularly those
that relates to equality between races
genders and social groups no it does
have a way to slap that in there yeah
she's like I will make all this stuff
out
calm it down over the pill yeah you know
choosing and I'll type in pills choosing
an alternative narrative about society
such narratives lean in many cases
towards racism massage
and other highly controversial beliefs
while this is not true of every single
person who would consider themselves red
pilled the members of pretty much every
alt-right group that you might have
heard of in cells neo-nazis eco fascists
will often consider themselves to have
awakened in this way to their fringe
theories and socially unacceptable eise
awakened literally the word woke
references you in the exact same thing
you're talking about also all trite
groups include go hashes that was my
question is that where we go fascists I
mean I know who they are the Earth
Liberation Front hearse liberation my
gosh
maybe they were playing Final Fantasy
seven what they're doing yeah there's
some eco-terrorism so then she tells us
what is this who cares
oh my god this is the best part she's
lying I love this it's such a good
example of how fake news works all
evanka did was say taken that's it
there's a red rose there trigger was it
a red pull about being a socialist maybe
I could argue that or that she she heard
that taking a red pill means you voted
for Trump and she's like well of course
I did she just done thought of a
reference to the matrix in denote a man
true boom and so here's what we get
Ivanka Trump's tweets suggests that the
Trump children are familiar with and
perhaps sympathetic to some of the more
radical internet communities my goodness
not the first time the Trump's have
employed the language of the alt-right
Donna does that snow thing like are they
still trying to do this they all right
they're still try Donald June I think
it's the left trying to convince
everybody that I mean I'm sure they're
still around yeah right I'm talking
about the media all I'm seeing so far is
her trying to convince the group around
her that the everybody that isn't left
with them is all right right that's what
the same yep Donald Jr has likened liked
and retweeted controversial internet
figures so just Mike certamen and Alex
show while Eric trump infamous infamous
infamously used the anti-semitic
internet term checkles in an interview
on Fox News didn't even hear literally a
reference to Israeli money isn't that
what it is though yeah but that's all
it's ever been hints close you watch
sure I could Morty yeah and Rick and
Morty they go to
where they have schmeckel Michael is
Rick and Marty giving alt right dog
whistles well now that they heard it
from right here for shekels wait oh yeah
it's ridiculous our bread it's for a
chant blah blah blah oh my god this
tweet from Ivanka suggested no no it
suggests nothing she said the word taken
we have no idea what she meant what it
means we can assume a lot of things but
you wrote what was this 500 words
expressing about your interpretation of
the alt right and eco fascism based on
her saying the word had taken it's
ridiculous this is insane
she's and she's thrown 4chan in there
she's probably everything everything's
in there sprite anything that she could
shove into this to like you got a
pattern make the right length yes I'm
just imagining she's like wow she's in
the writing kitchen just like smiling to
do and like sprinkling and all right and
making she's like open space evanka
tweeted one single word so I'm just
gonna mix all of these things together
and then I don't know what happened put
in the oven see what comes out I'm gonna
call it the woke pie her capacity to
normalize dangerous offensive and
willfully perverse ideologies should not
be underestimated
simply by using their language she takes
what belongs on the murkier corners of
the internet and gives it the
presidential amazing I am jealous Oh
like they get to write this stuff you
know to do this look look at her picture
she loves herself too she's doing the
exact same poses Ivanka and I'm here for
it oh my gosh did she choose that photo
on purpose man they look alike actually
it's kind of creepy maybe it's just
jealousy and like but here's the other
question too like what a Milani ever do
anybody should even say anything she
speaks like eight languages she's like
so nice she's so polished but they just
really go after and the only time you
ever see her she's like sitting there
smiling like doing nothing she's read
books to kids right I don't know like
only she made a tennis court
did she yeah
like one of the conference's yes not
like they complained that she like had
made plans to put outside of this court
at the White House so this is how you
know she's the first lady she could do
that like okay and Trump should get the
exercise to be honest for sure good this
is the perfect example of what Trump
derangement syndrome is yeah like how
much they hate Ivanka and she says one
word and they're like they make this
whole world on about what's really going
on and it's like I mean you made all
that up dude that like that article it
was a hundred percent BS yeah I know it
up every single word yeah I mean she she
didn't she didn't pull any facts out at
all I didn't say anything it was just we
can assume that she did all of this I
figured it out Wow up ten figure it out
enlighten us Tim I don't think there
actually is a human being named Sarah
man devis oh yeah oh it is a drawing
it's a drawing through the drawing this
in my opinion is an AI who designed to
write articles SJW AI yes well leftists
what they do is all the words are
already pre-programmed in alright that's
why eco fascists made no sense because
the computer is just mashing words
together mm-hmm this seriously feels
like every single thing they could have
shoved in there they did are the words
top in there no I don't actually maybe
did they type it in let's see it yeah
now this is this is a it's impressive
did you guys read that article from the
Ben Smith The New York Times no oh I saw
you posted at the amazing um Ben Smith
wrote a take down
I'm calling to take down you can't get
mad at me of Ronan Farrow okay pointing
out that you know Ronan Farrow was this
hero of you know of journalism I guess I
don't want to point him on any political
faction anything okay but he broke the
Weinstein story the meet these big me
two scandals oka and Ben Smith just torn
apart he was like in his book he loved
just like conspiracies he can't back up
he makes points and then you know Ben's
like I fact checked this
this is not true it just really tears
into him and he points out that there's
this like resistance journalism I think
this is from a previous article he wrote
the resistance journalism or maybe it's
this one where they're just
conspiratorial minded like they think
the worst possible things and they make
things up it's all narrative driven and
one of his criticisms I could be
butchering all this so you really should
just check out the article he wrote it
speaks better for itself because if I'm
getting it wrong I mean no disrespect
Ben I don't get mad at me
but he basically says that Ronan Farrow
has this desire for this cinematic
quality of stories and that when you
hear them you're like that could be a
movie and that's a problem yeah so it's
like the Weinstein thing Harvey
Weinstein is like everything is like
exaggerated to a great deal to a great
degree okay I'm like well the guy did do
a bunch of crazy things he even like
backed up one of the claims made against
Matt Lauer who got removed from his job
was like not true so he basically
debunked some of these claims made by
Ronan Farrow then people actually lost
their jobs for them Oh totally yeah for
their lives
yeah but I mean I think there's a lot
about you know Matt Lauer and Weinstein
that are confirmed but he points out not
all of it was like one of the things he
points out this article is that Ronan
Farrow alleges basically I'm saying
basically cuz I don't you know I wanna
make sure the context could be you
opinion but Hillary Clinton was
intervening to stop his story and Harvey
Weinstein okay
and it was perfect the perfect narrative
the seedy establishment elite protecting
her friend and what Ben Smith uncovered
was actually the clintus a lawyer for
hillary clinton like her companies or
whatever contacted Ronan Farrow not to
pressure him to stop to confirm if the
story was real so they wouldn't do
business with Weinstein basically like I
guess been verified some text messages
where the guy said if this stuff he's
saying about Harvey is true we don't
want to do business with him okay so he
called and said can you confirm this
what did what did Ronan Farrow write he
called me saying he was concerned about
this clearly an attempt to pressure me
into backing off the story of course so
anyway I bring this up because this is
basically what that what they've done
and like what what the story you know
about Ivanka Trump and the red pill is
you know these outlets they write
narratives they get the story in their
mind and then they're like oh I really
want to spread a story about LA
a president's daughter who's a racist
eco fascist who hears Ivanka and she
said the word taken perfect
that's my narrative that's my in I got
this I'll tell you I'll tell you a story
man I don't know if I told the story
before when I was working for fusion
okay I so this is the ABC news Univision
company I remember those days yeah yeah
yeah yeah Miami you were there so I'm
working for them and I'm sitting the
office in New York I'm doing my things I
do video documentary and stuff and I
hear them doing their month there
they're like morning news briefing okay
and this one dudes like I got a crazy
story this is crazy
apparently on imager right the web site
IMG you are okay there's like tens of
thousands of uploads of this picture of
the monopoly man and he's got puppet
strings and it's like Facebook and
Google and Twitter and no one knows why
all of these uploads like all of these
different links someone's uploading all
these photos and I'm hearing this and
while he's talking I google it six
months ago
story resolved when when if when a 404
error occurred on the website and it
would auto redirect to a random file
name okay it was one upload one time
they wrote the story he he knew what the
story was he didn't do any research he
went in the meetings that here's what
I'm gonna write and they said do it and
then he did and while he was pitching it
I googled it and I'm like this is not
true
yeah why are they writing this and I
told him and they were like well you
know we'll look into it I was told that
at that company they would often change
articles without notice without without
editing histories without notifications
stealth editing articles and they didn't
want to say anything because they they
don't wanna call anyone else how because
a would called out too there it is you
know they go in the meetings you know
and they say what are you writing today
I have this great story I'm going to
write they never asked him if it was
true or not they were like cool do it
and it wasn't it wasn't real
I gotta say the SJW AI sounds scary man
I wonder if someone opens not sure I
don't think it would be that difficult
to make an AI where you could like load
up a website and then it's like give us
a name of someone and we'll write some
you know the AI will automatically
generate like yeah how long a bigot
that's what this article feels like but
it was a
generated yeah it doesn't it doesn't
make any sense oh man and and oh oh no
that also explains why she's posing the
same as Ivanka with blonde hair wearing
a red dress then the AI saw the picture
and nothing else to go but only
reference it head for the person was my
gosh I think you might be right
I'm kidding by the way someone's gonna
clip this and they're gonna be like look
at these crazy conspiracy theorists
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you